Ich hab dich enttäuscht. Er entfernt sich immer weiter von mir. Ich hab dich enttäuscht. Diese quälenden Sekunden. Bitte treib keinen Keil zwischen uns, Stefan ist ohnehin. Er entfernt sich immer weiter von mir. Weiter von mir. Bitte treib keinen Keil zwischen uns, Stefan ist ohnehin, er entfernt sich immer weiter von mir. Ich habe dich enttäuscht. Ja gut, hallo, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid, bei dieser vielleicht etwas melancholischeren, ruhigeren Ausgabe von Das Podcast ist auf jeden Fall mit! Und Florentin Will! Dankeschön, vielen, vielen Dank. Auch herzlichen Glückwunsch an den Komponisten dieses Intros. Florentin! Ja, Copyright-technisch haben wir da noch ein paar Sachen am Laufen. Ich sag mal so, meine Rechtsanwaltschaft ist da in Kontakt. Marlon hat uns dieses Intro geschickt. Bitte, bitte treibt keinen Keil zwischen uns. Bitte, bitte treibt keinen Keil zwischen uns. Bitte, bitte treibt keinen Keil zwischen uns. Und neu, diesmal hat dieses Intro auch einen eigenen Titel. Keil? Normalerweise bekommen wir einfach nur Intro hier, Final, Final, Final, raus damit, Export. Final Version zwei. Sowas. Aber hier haben wir tatsächlich auch einen Titel, nämlich diese quälenden Sekunden von Marlon.
Vielen, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Einstieg, für diese kleine Rutsche, für diese kleine Eisfläche, mit der wir galant in die Folge kommen, in der wir einiges zu besprechen haben.
Ich finde, wenn ein Titel ist Final 2 oder Final V2, das hatte ich auch im beruflichen Kontext, gab es oft eine Version Final V2 und dann reicht das oft schon bei so Mitarbeitergesprächen, so was ist dein Feedback, was hat nicht gut funktioniert, reicht einfach nur ein Screenshot davon, um zu zeigen, everything is fucked. Da ist was schiefgegangen, ja. Nein, alles ist fucked. Weil nichts sagt mehr, dass nichts funktioniert, wie Version Final V2. Das fände ich aber auch mal schön für so ein Museum der Filmgeschichte, gibt es ja bestimmt so die Dateinamen von den abgegebenen Screenplays, so irgendwie Aaron Sorkin, The Social Network, Final, Really, Done, Now, I'm Done, Done, Really, Final, ganz viele L's. Aaron Edit, Aaron Re-Edit, Revised. Ignore the Mistake on Page Three, sow was, ich glaube, das ist ganz geil. Ich weiß gar nicht, also ich meine, du kennst dich natürlich aus in der Branche. Gibt es da Konventionen zur Benennung von Datei oder schmeißt man da einfach seine Export-Export-Final jetzt hier migrate-movie-idea dot pdf oder sowas, schmeißt man das mal rüber? Ja, und dann so Vista-Migration. Ja, so ein ganz ein ganz merkwürdiges Dateiformat, so MKF. Nee, ich kenne es ja wenn dann nur von der Drehbuchseite, und da ist es wirklich scheißegal. Zumal man schickt das dann irgendwo hin, an Leute, die das dann verteilen und so, und die benennen das am meisten nochmal um. Das heißt, man hat eine gewisse Narrenfreiheit. Ich verstehe. Es ist aber nicht gut für die eigene, weil man kriegt so oft die Frage, hast du noch, hör mal, hast du noch mal Version 4 oder so, oder hast du noch mal Drehbuch 4, dass man sich selber einen Gefallen tut. Man baut aber auch kleine Gags ein, irgendwie Star Wars oder so, Huge Spoiler on Page 8 oder so. The Last Jedi, FTX, nein, es ist so wenig Platz, marginal viel Platz für Gags in Büchern. Schade, schade. Ja, schade oder aus einem guten Grund. Ich finde, man sollte schon Spaß haben bei der Arbeit, egal was man macht. Ich schaue aktuell, ich weiß nicht, eine tolle Doku zum Thema, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt eine Welt für dich zusammenbricht, aber etwas, das wir auch in Deutschland kennen, nämlich die Monopoly-McDonalds-Lotterie. Und da gab es einen riesigen Skandal in den USA, weil irgendjemand aus der Fabrik die Gewinner geklaut hat. Genau. Also die Idee ist, man sammelt Dinge, man sammelt Strassen, man hat ein Monopoly-Brett quasi vor sich und man kriegt für manche Dinge aus dem McDonald's-Kosmos Aufkleber. Genau. Und wenn man da, sagen wir mal, zweimal den gleichen hat, die die Schlossallee, also das Pendant halt so der krassen Strasse, wenn man da das Pärchen hat, kriegt man wieviel Euro, Dollar? Ja, was mich am meisten enttäuscht hat, ist, dass der Hauptgewinn, eine Million Dollar, eine Million Dollar, war ein Sofortgewinn, war nicht mal Parkstrasse, Schlossallee. Ich dachte nämlich auch, dass der höchste Gewinn die blauen Straßen sind, nicht der Fall, sondern es waren Sofortpreise und da hat jemand einfach irgendwie sich am Ende der Produktionslinie hingestellt und hat die mit der Zunge wie so ein Chamäleon aus der Fabrikhalle rausgesaugt und hat die dann weiterverkauft. Das heißt, niemand konnte tatsächlich gewinnen. Und das Tolle war, das FBI, die diesen ganzen Fall aufgerollt hat, hat dann irgendwann mal alle Gewinner eingeladen zu so einem Reunion und so. Alle Gewinner, von denen sie wussten, dass die nicht tatsächlich gewonnen haben, sondern das irgendwie gekauft haben auf dem Schwarzmarkt oder geschenkt bekommen haben von ihrem Mafia-Aufgleich. Dann die Tür abgeschlossen und gesagt haben, so, jetzt reden wir mal Tacheles. Genau. Tacheles, Tacheles. Und dann haben diese Interview, ja, und wie haben sie das nochmal bekommen und so und was war das für ein Tag für sie? Und die hatten richtig Spaß bei der Arbeit, weil die haben dann auch so Sachen gesagt wie, bei welcher McDonald's Filiale haben Sie denn den Gewinn dann eingefordert? Ja, bei der da in New Jersey und dann geben die dir so ein Bild von dieser Filiale. Ach, die hier in New Jersey, ja, ja, genau die. Das ist nicht in New Jersey. Und er so im Talking jetzt so, ja, irgendwo in Alabama oder so. Und die hatten so viel Spaß dabei und die haben dann die die Leute extra noch mal vor so die Karte gestellt. Und ja, hier ... Das ist gerade eine Netflix-Doku. Das ist, ich glaube, HBO-Doku oder so. Aber es ist fantastisch. Ja, weil ich, wenn ich eine Million Dollar gewinne, und dann kommt ein Anruf von nicht FBI, sondern hier ist, weiß ich nicht, Gewinnspielkommission, was auch immer. Wir haben noch mal ein paar Fragen zu ihrem Gewinn. Würde ich, glaube ich, immer die Fragen zu meinem Gewinn ignorieren. Zumal, wenn ich weiss, es ist was Falsches. Jetzt hat er nicht das FBI als FBI angerufen, sondern als McDonald's Promotion. Als drei andere Buchstaben. Aber das finde ich auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Und ja, es ist eine spannende Geschichte. Und am Ende flog es auf, weil jemand gemerkt hat, dass alle Gewinner Teil der gleichen Familie sind, obwohl sie andere Nachnamen haben und dann hat er das FBI angerufen und so, dann ist dann alles kaputt gegangen.
Aber das ist ja oft das Problem von Verbrechern, dass sie eitel sind, dass sie vor die Kamera wollen, dass sie nochmal mit den Leuten reden wollen und sich den Medien aussetzen und so werden sie dann immer gefasst. Das ist ja das Problem.
Das ist das Problem.
Dass der Verbrechertyp auch gleich der Typ ist, der gefasst wird.
Der gefasst werden will, ja. Oder jetzt, sagt Stefan Tietze natürlich mit seinem messerscharfen logischen Verstand, ist das jetzt nicht hier ein Bias, weil wir ja nur die fassen, die sich auch extra melden. Also fangen wir nur die Verbrechertypen, die sich auch anbieten, zu fangen. Da bin ich jetzt ganz gespannt auf deine Einschätzung davon, wie man das angehen soll. Das kann man ja wahrscheinlich ... Also ich glaube, dass sehr viele Mordfälle gelöst werden. Also nagelt mich jetzt da wieder nicht drauf fest. Ja. Ich finde auch gut, dass Experte immer den Vorsatz wegsteht, nagelt mich da nicht drauf fest. Aber ich bin mir noch sicher, dass die meisten Mordfälle geklärt werden. Und das würde ja dem entgegensetzen. Klar kennen wir nur die, die dann auch vor die Kamera wollen. Wir kennen aber auch eine ganze Menge Trottel, die irgendwelche Sachen falsch gemacht haben und so.
Ja. Und wie gesagt, ich bin gerade in so einem weirden, in so einer YouTube-Spiral drin, wo ich die ganze Zeit Videos von Verhörungen, Verhörungen, Verhörungs.
Ja, alles okay bei dir eigentlich, Stefan.
Wie gesagt, was ist die mehr als ...
Irgendwie nach deinem Unfall, nach deinem alkoholinduzierten Unfall bist du jetzt im Verhörmilieu, also alles okay.
Ich wollte nur mal ganz allgemein fragen, alles gut bei dir. Es ist alles gut, so, aber auch nur, weil ich das gerade ... Du schüttelst mit dem Kopf. Naja, das ist übrigens spannend. Du hast die Handfläche am Hals. Das ist wirklich eine Technik, die man dann erkennt, oft, wenn es die kleinste Dissonanz gibt, zwischen der Antwort eines Menschen, der gerade verhört wird, und der Bewegung, die er dabei macht. Zum Beispiel, du sagst, ich war da nicht da. So, und die Klopfer, um Dinge zu unterstreichen, gelernt, ein gelernter Mechanismus, passen aber gar nicht rhythmisch zu dem Satz, sondern es wäre ja eher, nochmal, ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht in der Stadt. Okay. So, das würde gepassen. Wenn es da aber so ein bisschen so ein ... so ein arhythmisches Trommel gibt, kein Scheiss. Wenn dann auch so bei Reggaeton wieder mit reinfließt. Ich war ... Zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht in der Stadt, nicht in der Stadt ... Ähm, Special Agent Mulder, ich glaube, wir haben es hier mit einem nicht ganz so ehrlichen Gesellen zu tun. Das klingt wie der Anfang des schlechten 90er-Jahres Musikvideos. Aber dann sind die Detectives darauf trainiert, dass sie sofort darauf gehen, immer wenn es diese Dissonanz gibt. Und dann habe ich wieder viel gelernt über die sogenannte Read-Technik, dass man sofort dem Befragten eine Möglichkeit gibt, dass das Ganze gar nicht so schlimm ist. Also man sagt ihm, entweder du bist ein Cold-Blooded-Killer, das habe ich vielleicht schon mal erzählt, oder man sagt ihm sowas wie, ja, wir sind Menschen, wir machen Fehler, es ist okay, es kann passieren. Und ihm direkt so eine Möglichkeit gibt, letzten Stroheim quasi, der ihm aber so ein Narrativ gibt, dass es nicht komplett eine irrationale, dumme Entscheidung war, jemanden umzubringen, sondern wir machen fehlermäßig, also wirklich so überempathisch. Und das ist wohl auch so ein Mittel, wo dann schnell Leute dann anfangen, sich zu öffnen und zu konfessen. Und dann ist es spannend, es gibt empirisch belegt eine Sitzposition, in der die meisten Leute dann zugeben, was sie gemacht haben. Nämlich lehnen sich nach vorne und schützen ihre Unterarme auf ihren Knien ab oder auf den Beinen ab. Und die Detectives, die spiegeln die ganze Zeit die Körperhaltung, die ganze Zeit, über stundenlang spiegeln die die Körperhaltung der Befragten. Das heißt, immer wenn die sich zurücklehnen, lehnen sich auch die Detektives zurück. So, dann konditionieren die die auch. Und konditionieren die und an irgendeinem Punkt, wenn die merken, gut, jetzt haben wir ihn ein bisschen gecrackt, lehnen die sich in diese Position, die dazu einlädt, zu confessen und machen dann quasi so, die greifen davor weg. Und oft rutscht dann auch, weil die ganze Zeit gespiegelt wurde, rutscht dann auch der Befragte in diese Position. Es ist so ein bisschen wie Dance Dance Evolution so, du machst die Bewegung vor, der andere macht sie nach. Richtig, genau. Und irgendwann weißt du nicht mehr, wer ist hier der Chef. Beeinflusse ich das Spiel oder beeinflusst das Spiel mich? Und dann muss ich mich hinsetzen. Also es ist wie Dance Dance Evolution. Ja, aber ich habe auch, gibt es ja nicht auch die Last Week Tonight Folge, wo gesagt wird, dass das alles super gemein ist und man da unschuldige Leute ins Gefängnis bringt mit diesen Techniken. Das ist nicht dein Problem. Aber möchte ich auch nochmal sagen. Aber wenn ich interessant bei... Ja, da findet ihr eine Fussnote in den Shownotes. Genau diese Technik habe ich auch in meiner Zivildienstarbeit mit Kindern gemacht. Genau diese gleiche Verhörtechnik. Mörder sind wie Kinder. Im Grunde, du hast ja die gleichen Probleme wie ein Ermittler, so du hast dann halt irgendwie keine Ahnung, Teller. Nur die Steaks sind viel geringer. Steaks sind viel geringer. Also wer hat die Nutella gegessen? Ja, da ist dann halt irgendwie so ein Brettspiel, wurde nicht abgebaut, nachdem er gespielt hat. So, und dann gehe ich auf den Tatort, erstmal mit den Gummihandschuhen, mit dem Kreide, machst du so ein rechterliches Feld, und dann sage ich, hm, tja, mein Bauch sagt, Teresa aber wir wollen jetzt ja nicht mal zu schnell vorschnell eilen. Und dann gehst du auch zu den Kindern und sagst, wenn irgendwas passiert ist, dann sagt man, hast du das alleine gemacht oder mit jemand anderem? Also du gibst dem sofort die Möglichkeit, jemand anderen mit reinzuziehen, weil das machen die sofort. Wenn die die Möglichkeit haben, ein anderes Kind mit schuldig zu machen, dann sind die sofort dabei und dann kannst du mal sagen, wenn der Fussballer es nicht aufgehäumt, hast du Fussball gespielt oder mit dem Jochen? Nee, ich habe mit dem Jochen gespielt. Achso, aber der Jochen war ja zu der Zeit ganz woanders. Direkt ins Messer laufen lassen. Und dann kommen immer die Eltern von Theresa und sagen, die Theresa ist sehr verstört, kommt die neuerdings immer von der Kita zurück irgendwie. Und sie wird für Dinge beschuldigt, die sie gar nicht gemacht hat. Also irgendwie scheint hier eine False Confession Situation im Gange zu sein. Also irgendwie beschuldigen sie hier, testen sie hier Verhörtechniken des FBI an Kindern aus und zwingen die zu Geständnissen? Ach was, das würden wir doch hier nicht machen. Wir sind doch hier ein ehrbares, ehrliches Etablissement. Ja, weil Theresa ist ein bisschen verstört von ihrem Etablissement. Das sollte sie auch sein. Wissen Sie eigentlich, was Ihre Theresa hier anstellt so den ganzen Tag? Es ist ein liebes Kind, wir kriegen nur tolle Sachen zu hören, immer die ganze Zeit von Freunden. Nach einem neunzehnstündigen Verhör haben wir endlich aus ihr rausbekommen, dass sie die Snoopy-Tasse runtergeschmissen hat. Ja? Wir dachten sie... Warum muss sie neunzehn Stunden verhört werden? Warum muss das so lange dauern? Sie sollte vielleicht gar nicht neunzehn Stunden... Wir dachten, das wäre irgendwie so ein Sleepover hier. Haben Sie sie so schlecht erzogen oder Sie und Ihr Mann? Naja, also mein Mann und ich, wir teilen uns die Erziehung. Aha, also sind Sie auch dafür verantwortlich. Ja, also wir beide erziehen, natürlich erziehen wir unsere Tochter. Mehr brauche ich nicht. Scheiße, scheiße. Schatz, ich habe gestanden. Ja, ich glaube, mit der richtigen Feuertechnik kannst du jedem dazu bringen, alles zu sagen. Das ist ja auch dieses, mit diesen falschen Geständnissen, das dann immer vor Gericht heißt, ja, ja, hat er gestanden, was nicht erwähnt wird, nach einem 13-stündigen Folterverhör hat er gestanden, sondern, ne, hat er gesagt. Naja. Und, aber zurück nochmal zu der Losnummer, weil irgendwann habe ich mal aus meiner Mutter herausbekommen, nach dem 19-stündigen Verhör, dass sie früher immer in einer Losfabrik gearbeitet hat. Oh ja, das ist ja gut. Und wenn man halt Eltern fragt, was ihre vorherigen Jobs waren, was das Leben vor einem selbst waren. Die reden da nicht gern drüber. Nee, es kommt langweiliger Bullshit, es kommt oft langweiliger Bullshit. So, und dann ist mir später aufgefallen, dass man mal, man muss sie zu dem Kram bringen, der ja eigentlich erzählenswert ist. Meine Mutter hat es nicht für erzählenswert gehalten, dass sie in einer fucking Los-Fabrik gearbeitet hat, wo dann Aufträge reinkommen, ja, wir brauchen so und so viel Tausend Lose. Und dann werden die da gedruckt. Geil. Und dann werden die wie für Kirmes-Jahrmärkte, die werden dann so gerollt, dann kommt so ein kleines Gummi drauf und so. Das heißt, es würde jetzt nicht viel bringen, sie könnte sie auch klauen und dann zum Jahrmarkt gehen, an denen die verkauft haben und sich dann den Bären holen. Genau. Ich glaube, da gibt es richtig, entweder gibt es gar keine Sicherheitsvorkehrungen oder ich weiß nicht genau. Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht. Oder sehr, sehr starke. Aber ich glaube nicht, sie kann sich den riesen Zwei-Meter-Bären dann da abholen. Das heißt, aber die Kunden legen die dann auch fest, wie viele Gewinner drin sind? Richtig, richtig. Die legen die Gewinner fest. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, die grosse Frage, wie geht man jetzt als ehrwürdiges Familienlosunternehmen, Los und Lose um, Los und Söhne, wie geht man damit um, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ja wir hätten gern 10.000 Monopoly-Straßen und so und ja, es sind alles Nieten, Dankeschön. Moment, wie ist es alles Nieten? Genau, alles Nieten. Moment, aber Sie schreiben doch in Ihrem Prospekt hier, dass man die Chance hat, eine Weltreise zu gewinnen und hier zehn Millionen Euro. Ja, damit Leute die auch kaufen. Warum sollten die denn sonst kaufen, wenn die, wir können nicht reinschreiben, es gibt nur Nieten, ne, verstehen Sie, wie ich meine? Okay, aber das, so wie den kann man gar nicht, okay. Hallo, sind Sie doch dran? Ich bin doch dran, ja. Achso, weil Sie schon das gesagt haben. Ja, ich habe gehofft, Sie gehen auf. Können wir nicht zumindest einen Gewinner reintun oder so? Weil es ist, ich glaube, rechtlich gesehen ist es Betrug. Ungern. Ich frage noch mal kurz, bleiben Sie kurz dran. Sind Sie noch dran? Singen Sie das? Hm? Hm? Ich dachte, es ist Platzhaltermusik.
Ja, es ist Platzhaltermusik. Ich stelle von den Kurs mit dem Kollegen und frage, ob das okay ist, dass wir einen Gewinner reinbauen, okay?
Okay.
Hi, hier bin ich wieder. Nee, kein Gewinner.
Gut, aber danke, dass Sie nochmal nachgefragt haben.
Ja, na klar. Vielen Dank. Wiederhören danke, dass Sie noch mal nachgefragt haben. Ja, na klar.
Vielen Dank.
Wiederhören.
Tschüss.
Und deswegen, aber ich glaube, ist ja die Frage, ob man da als Losenunternehmer sagt,
nee, das machen wir nicht. Solche Geschäfte machen wir nicht.
Vor allem, man könnte ja auch als korrupte Losbetreiber sagen, ja, geben Sie mir zehn Gewinner und dann, wenn die ankommen, schicke ich mir nicht.
Ja gut, aber muss man dann, die werden ja auch schon gemischt. So eine Mülleiner ihrer Nähe, sag ich mal, in der Nähe. Aber los und Söhne. Und in den Reihen einfach, rein damit. Hör auf, immer den Leuten zu sagen, die sollen sie den Reihen werfen. Die machen es nämlich. Die Gewinner und schmeiß die in den Fluss rein, ins Meer. Das Meer kennt kein Glück. Ne, sag ich mal, knick, knack. Ich weiß nicht, ob das... Sagen wir mal so. Es wäre, also, mehr kennen kein Glück. Sag ich mal, knick, knack. Ich weiß nicht, ob das... Sagen wir mal so. Also, mehr kennt kein Glück. Frag mal Ariel. An die hätte ich einige Fragen. Ja, ich auch. Die hätte ich wirklich einige. Vermisst sie ihr altes Leben? Weil am Ende kriegt sie ja Beine, kann auch laufen, Filmfehler, sofort, 16 Threads offen, warum kann Ariel direkt laufen, wenn sie ihren Fischschwanz durch Beine ersetzt?
Ist es also, sagt sie, Beine ist ja total Quatsch, ich will mir meine Flossen zurück.
Hat sie das jemals bereut?
Hat sie erst angefangen, quasi durch die Luft schwimmen zu wollen, wie so ein Idiot.
Das stimmt, ja, da liegt sie so am Boden und will so kraulen und dann sagt der Prinz, Ariel, bitte jetzt steh auf. Mensch, du machst es mir echt schwer. Ich musste hier extra diesen Fluch brechen oder gar nichts machen, keine Ahnung, um jetzt hier, dass du an Land kommst und jetzt so. Und der Vater von ihr ist nicht Poseidon, ist weder Neptun noch Poseidon, richtig? Wie heißt er nochmal? Reinhard, glaube ich. Reinhold. Reinhold. Mein Vater Reinhold, aber ich will doch auch ein normales Mädchen sein und an der...
Nein, niemals, Ariel.
Sebastian, was sagst du dazu?
Unter dem Meer, unter dem Meer.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, jetzt bei, ich habe Rings of Power durch.
Keine Angst, es wird nicht gespoilert, etc.
It is the rings of the power. Eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee Keine Angst, es wird nicht Das ist das Intro, ja. The Rings of Power. Offensichtlich von dem Deutschen. Aber das Intro fand ich so mittel? Aber ich will jetzt nicht über das Ende so viel reden. Man bla, ist es doch vorbei, könnt ihr angucken oder lasst es sein, aber es ist die ganze...
Aus dem Beat oder guckt ihr gucken oder lasst es sein oder rein oder schaut es euch an, was eure Meinung euch sagt. Intelliganz allein. Was ich nur sagen möchte, ist, es ist eigentlich 90 Prozent Leute fragen ihren Boss slash König, ob sie etwas machen, raten den, wir müssen das und das machen. Der Boss oder König oder die Königin ist irrational anti, niemand weiß warum, es ist auch nie wirklich erklärt, immer so, nee, machen wir nicht. Und dann macht er oder sie das alleine, die es vorgeschlagen hat. Wird dann vom König überrascht, aber dann wird gezeigt, nee, das hat schon gute Bewandtnis gehabt, dass es gemacht wurde. Das Thema ist überzeugen. Überzeugen, ablehnen, alleine machen. Nee, okay, und dann passiert irgendwas und dann wird es doch gemacht. Und man weiß nicht, wegen der Überzeugung oder weil was anderes passiert. Schw zu sagen. Charakter hat eine Idee, muss aber erst Chef überzeugen. Chef sagt immer nein, und das geht mir langsam im Film auf die Nerven. Dieser unbegründet anti-eingestellte Chef. Ja, Hindernisse, du kennst es. Ja, aber die müssen auch begründet sein. Obstacles. Es sind einfach so Generic-Könige und Königinnen Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Obst. Der hat das einfach gemacht. Du bleibst zu Hause, Frodo. Frodo, du bleibst hier. Noch mindestens für eine Saison. Brauche ich dich hier. Moment, jetzt bin ich Franchises. Wie ist Saison? Du meinst jetzt für die Kürbisball-Saison? Frodo ist doch auf Tatooine gefangen. Nein, nein, nein. Frodo ist der Torwart im Kürbisball-am von dem Auenland. Und dieses grosse Spiel steht an. Genau. Das grosse Spiel steht an. Die Kürbisweitschuss, nee, Kürbisballs. Genau. Frodo stimmt im Tor und er ist der Beste im Tor. Aber er wurde auch erst ins Tor gestellt, weil er für alle anderen Positionen nicht geeignet war. Ja. Sam ist im St Sam ist im Sturm, Marion Pippen sind die Cheerleader und ab und zu ist Gandalf im Publikum und ja, macht die Saison spannender. Ja, das stimmt schon. Komisch, dass dann immer Foto gewinnen. Wenn jemand weit hinten liegt, fallen auch zu über Zubel noch ein paar Tore. Und es wird auch mal spannend. Immer nur, wenn Gandalf im Publikum sitzt. Da gab es die ersten Gerüchte, dass er vielleicht was mit magischen Kräften am Hut hat. Im Hute hat. Das war für mich die beste Szene in ganz Harry Potter, war, wo die Quidditch spielen und der eine Zauberer im Publikum sitzt und den einfach anzündet, der da spielt. Wo ich mir denke, ja, genau das würde passieren in der Welt voll Zauberern. Jetzt habt ihr endlich die Prämisse mal zu Ende gedacht. Natürlich würden die ständig eingreifen. Was ist denn das jetzt für eine... Nein, nein, also Professor Squirrel verzaubert Harry's Besen und Snape versucht, einen Gegenfluch anzuwenden und Hermine zündet Snape an. Du denkst jetzt und nein, nein, nein, McGonagall macht einen Gegenzauber gegen den Gegenzauber von Snape. Das Gegengift gegen mich der Gegenfluch Du bist der Schnatz doch das Squid-It-Spiel steht fünf zu fünf. Ja, was? Genau so. Die beiden verwirrendsten Dinge der Welt, Christina Stürmer und Quidditch-Regeln. Was? Aber das würde doch ständig passieren, also bei jedem Quidditch-Spiel in der Zaubererwelt. Das würde ständig passieren. Welchen Aspekt von dieser Kaskade meinst du? So, das Spiel musste schon wieder abgebrochen werden, weil leider wieder jemand aus dem Publikum den Besen angezündet hat. Damit wird das Spiel verschoben auf Donnerstag. Gibt's halt jedes Spiel muss immer wieder verschoben werden. Gibt's Donnerstag? Ja, ich glaube, es gibt Donnerstag. Ich stelle dem Buch mal irgendwann, Harry muss Donnerstag, siebte Stunde immer wahr sagen. Ja, es gibt doch, ein Buch ist doch Schaltjahr, da sagen die, schnell, wir müssen uns beeilen, das ist Schaltjahr. Das ist ein Trimagische Turnier, nur weil es alle vier Jahre ist, heißt es nicht, dass es Schaltjahr ist. Doch, ich glaube, die haben auch Sommerzeit, Winterzeit, das ist alles so. Du kannst ja nicht alles in deinem Buch erklären, alles, was du nicht explizit ansprichst, ist halt so wie in echt. In Star Wars gibt es auch Uhrzeiten, vier und dreissig. Aber du kannst doch nicht sagen, ich hab siebte Stunde Donnerstag immer wahr sagen. Das kann ich nicht. Doch, ich glaub schon. Donnerstag ... Das wird sich so weit. Glaubst du, wenn Harry Potter in die Winkelgasse geht, dann sagt Hagrid übrigens, wir haben hier andere Wochentage, wir haben hier acht Wochentage. Ja, Lora, Luna, Luna ... Slytherin-Tag, Hufflepuff-Tag, Flavor-Tag, Berry-Beans-Tag und es sind acht. Und dann Harry, Moment mal, das ist im gesamten Buch immer, welcher Wochentag ist heute? Und man denkt sich, warum habt ihr das eingeführt? Warum ist das so kompliziert, dass das größte Problem für Harry immer ist, welcher Wochentag heute? Nee, ich meine ja gerade, es wird nicht angesprochen, weil es wäre ja merkwürdig. Sie spricht ja auch nie vom Dezember oder sowas, würde ich mal behaupten, sondern immer nur von den Saison. Also sie würde wahrscheinlich um den Herbst sagen. Sie hat die Bücher vor elf Jahren gelesen, Stefan. Wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, sie spricht nie von Dezember. Das ist, wow, das ist eine ganz schöne Aussage, Stefan. Das sind Bücher, die du vor zwölf Jahren gelesen hast und jetzt sagst du hier, ja sie schreibt hier nie. nie ... Sorry, wir machen Comedy, wir machen keinen Fakten-Podcast. Sie benutzen nie einen Semikolon. Alter, ist das hier Deutschlandfunk oder was? Wir müssen uns nicht auf Quellen ziehen. Aber bin ich nicht voll. Aber bin ich nicht voll mit deinem Schwachsins-Fakten-Gelaber. Ja, okay. Nee, ich meine nur, wahrscheinlich redet sie nur, und das würde ich zumindest machen, wenn ich ein episches Fantasy-Franchise mache, so bescheuert, bis Donnerstag müssen wir in Mordor sein. Klingt doch einfach bescheuert. Ja, es stimmt schon. Sechste August sind wir in Mordor. Nein, bis die Sonne, die den Mond verschiebt oder so. Genau, bis die Sonne den Mond küsst oder so. Oder bis zum dritten Morgen. Gandalf sagt ja nicht, Donnerstag zwölf Uhr stehe ich hier auf der Matte, sondern er sagt, schaut gen Osten. Gandalf, wann wirst du zurückkehren? Ja, muss ich mal meinen Terminkalender gucken. Ich würde so sagen, also Donnerstag, Donnerstag morgen acht kann ich, naja, lass mal acht der dreissig sagen, weil ich habe da erst noch diesen Handwerkertermin bei mir zu Hause. Okay, meinst du nicht, du könntest dich beeilen, weil es ist die Schlacht von Helmsklamm und wir sind in Not. Ja, komm. Okay. Ja, ich komm Mittwoch
morgen. Oh, das wär super nett.
Mittwoch morgen acht steh ich hier auf der Matte.
Pünktlich. Wie die Maurer. Okay.
Danke, Gandalf. Wie Maurer Labingi
steh ich hier auf der... Pünktlich wie der
Maurer steh ich hier auf der Matte.
Wer ist Maurer? Nee, ist egal.
Nee, komm. Das wird jetzt hier
für den Film zu weit.
Okay, aber gut, dass wir es überhaupt angesprochen haben.
Verbleiben wir so. Gut,
alles klar, ciao. Das wäre doch weird,
das wäre doch fucking weird. Deswegen sagst du,
am ersten Sonnenlicht des dritten
Tages. Das macht ja Sinn.
Das ist ja schön zu hören und das ist,
da bleibt man der Fantasy treu. Wenn er sagt, Donnerstag
oder Juli,
weird, alles weird. Genau wie May the 4th,
ich werde am 4. Mai bei euch sein.
Funktioniert halt nicht so gut,
weil am 4. Mai werde ich bei euch sein, ist nicht
Die oder Juli, weird, alles weird. Genau wie May the 4th, ich werde am 4. Mai bei euch sein, funktioniert halt nicht so gut, weil am 4. Mai werde ich bei euch sein, ist nicht der beste Catchphrase für so ein Fantasy-Universum. Sogar noch kryptischer, der 4. Mai wird bei euch sein. Ja, im Sinne von, es wird unser Tag oder so, unser Game, unser Spiel, weiß ich nicht. So, na ja, wie gesagt, deswegen hat meine Mutter mir nie gesagt, dass sie in einer Losfabrik gearbeitet hat. Ja, vielleicht, weil sie geklaut hat. Also ich möchte jetzt hier nichts unterstellen, an der Mutter der Diebstahlerei. Ne, kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Moral ist flexibel. Aber ihr wart ja schon recht wohlhabend, sag ich mal. Also, du bist ja schon mit dem goldenen Skateboard unter den Füssen geboren worden. Mit dem goldenen Busse unter den Füssen? Ich glaube, nee, eher nicht. Und er ist sich auch sehr korrekt. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das gemacht hätte.
Aber ich finde es total spannend, dieser Ort, dieser mystische Ort, wo Lose... Ja, es gibt aber auch große Sicherheitsbestimmungen. Das wird in der Doku auch angesprochen.
Und es ist tatsächlich so...
Kannst du mich jetzt hier nicht hin, sondern deutlich.
Ja, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, klar, Bude am Jahrmarkt steht ja nicht drauf, die Gewinnchancen hier den goldenen großen,
den goldenen zwei Meter Blühsperren zu bekommen, liegt bei eins zu drei Millionen.
Das stimmt. Ja, stimmt. Aber muss man da nicht, kommt auch darauf an, ob man dann selber was leisten muss,
ob man irgendwas irgendwo reinwerfen muss, aber dann braucht man keine Lose, stimmt schon. Die Losbuden, diese klassischen, sind riesige Stände mit einer Milliarde Gewinnen.
Ich erinnere mich noch, dass ich im Urlaub war und dann waren wir Irland, Schottland oder irgendwie sowas und da gab es so eine Losbude und die Idee war, man kriegt ein Los mit einer Zahl drin und ungerade Zahlen gewinnen. Was super clever ist, weil man ja instinktiv denkt, ah okay, dann ist die Chance 50-50. Also dachte ich als achtjährige Junge. Wenn es die Null gibt, nicht. Ach Gott. Okay, komm, welches Mathe-Video hast du wieder gesehen, wo gesagt wird, dass die Null gerade oder ungerade? Besonder Menschenverstand. Und dann ist das eigentlich schlau, weil ich als Kind denke, ah okay, dann kaufe ich zwei Lose, habe ich einen Gewinn. Stellst du dich raus? Nein, habe alles verballert. Mein Bruder hat eine Eisbären gewonnen, ich nicht. Du meinst, aber du unterstellst jetzt dem Losbudenbesitzer, dass er ... Nein, ich unterstelle deiner Mutter, dass sie den Losbudenbesitzer dazu gebracht hat, dass gegen mich ... Die Losbude wirkt gegen mich. Du bist das Los, doch das Gewinnerglück wirkt gegen mich. So, jetzt halten wir den Song hier mal an. Nee, aber Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Außerdem ist es die dritte Strophe, die singen wir nicht. Okay, von Christina Stömer. Nur an Weihnachten. Nein, die singen wir nur an Weihnachten oder zur WM. Nee, ich möchte sagen, du unterstellst gerade den Los, den Busbodenbizzer, dass er nur gerade Zahlen hatte? Ja, genau. Oder ganz wenig ungerade, dass es halt nicht eins zu eins ist, aber man denkt sofort, es ist eins zu eins. Aber es war falsch. Ich weiss gar nicht, was aus diesem Eisbär geworden ist. Man kennt ja immer so diese Montagen, also ich kenne ja Bücher. Ja, Merk, die kenne ich nur aus Montagen. Ich kenne ja Bücher. Diese Buchschabenbuden da. Ich kenne das ja nur aus Montagen, dass man dann so auf ein Date, ja, und dann schiesst man so und dann kriegt sie diesen riesen Bären. Was passiert mit dem? Wo landen diese riesigen Bären? Die meisten werden schon auf dem Rückweg verloren oder vergessen. Ja, und die liegen dann irgendwo ganz traurig und am nächsten Tag gehen die Leute morgens und montags an so einem nassen Bären vorbei. Oder ich weiß, tatsächlich läuft ja gerade, ich bin ja immer noch drin im Dota 2, Flare, die International das große Turnier läuft aktuell. Und tatsächlich gibt es leider grosse Probleme bei diesem Turnier, denn ein Altbekannter taucht wieder auf, Grossvater Covid ist wieder mit dabei. Das heißt, es kam jetzt schon ein paar Mal vor, dass komplett ganze Teams in Quarantäne mussten. Bei einem Team war es so, Dota-Teams ... Sorry, aber das ist so duselig, es ist so dumm. Es ist so dumm, es ist ein Online-Spiel, das ist ja für gemacht, dass du alleine im Keller sitzt. Wenn eine Industrie davon nicht betroffen sein sollte, dann Dota-Fucking-Zwei. Ja, man trifft sich halt einmal im Jahr. Dota-Drei, verstehe ich. Konzept, wir haben uns verrannt. Mit den Pedalen und den Paddeln, wo du den Ball gegen die Wand dotzen musst, da musst du vor Ort sein. Ja, wo du mit dem Fahrrad und Golfschlägern quasi Baseball spielst. Das haben wir uns alle verrannt. Aber da war es jetzt so, dass in einem Team die Teams sind immer fünf Spieler und vier haben positiv getestet und einer nicht. Und dann gibt es ja immer diese grossen Bühnen, wo die Teams dann so auflaufen und dann kamen halt auf der einen Seite die fünf Spieler des anderen Teams und auf der anderen Seite kam halt so ein Typ raus. Ach, die zocken dann gegeneinander? Ja, die spielen gegeneinander dort. Aber why? Moment, Moment, weil die anderen zu Hause sind dann? Nee, die sind in Hotels und werden dann sozusagen zugeschaltet. Die spielen dann online, wie du gerade gesagt hast quasi. Ah, die spielen dann online, okay, okay. Aber die Idee ist ja, dass es ein LAN-Event ist, wo alle in einer Arena gegenüber sind. Und dann kam halt nur so ein Typ, setzt sich halt alleine auch an diesen riesigen Tisch mit den fünf Plätzen und damit es nicht ganz so leer ist, haben die auf die anderen vier Plätze große Teddybären gesetzt. Ah, okay, okay. Teddybären mit Masken haben die da an ihm gesetzt. Und das war einfach so, vor allem Leute, die einfach mal so reinsäppen. Das wäre so lustig, wenn ein Teddybär anfängt, mega gut zu spielen. Und plötzlich so, Teddybär hat Reich genommen. Ist Reich ein Held? Weiß ich nicht. Und dann einfach so, also wir haben uns jetzt überlegt, die Performance von dem Teddy war ganz gut, wir würden dich jetzt aus dem Team nehmen oder erstmal auf die Ersatzbank. Wieso, der ist doch einfach nur umgefallen auf die Tastatur. Ja, aber es hat leider genau im richtigen Moment hat er sein Ultimate aktiviert und dadurch hat er das ganze Spiel gewonnen. Ja, aber Leute, aber das kenne ich ja auch. Naja, leider in der letzten Zeit nicht so, also wir würden dich dann ersetzen gegen Bär Nummer drei. Bär Nummer drei, hätte ich meinen Namen? Nee, wir haben denen keinen Namen gegeben, aber tut mir leid. Das war's dann. Ja, okay. Ja, also Pressemitteilung, obwohl die Bären Masken getragen hat, müssen wir leider sagen, dass alle vier Bären positiv auf Corona getestet wurden. In ihrer Covid-Krankung erlegen sind. Und dann so ein Bild von so einer, wo so Ärzte ums Leben kämpfen, auf so einer Intensivstation. Ja, und die Ärzte dann so traurig, die dann so raustragen in so einen großen Container rein. Ach so, ich dachte, es ist so Bärenfamilie, wo dann die Eltern. Ja, sie haben leider auch verloren, das war sehr traurig. Die Bären haben verloren. Die Bären haben verloren. Und dann gibt es ja danach immer so ein Handshake. Die Teams laufen so aneinander vorbei und schütteln sich gegenseitig die Hände. Hat das nur der alleine gemacht und ich dachte mir, warum läuft nicht einer der Spieler auch zu den Bären und schüttelt den Bären die Hände. Hat keiner gemacht, weil es ein tragischer Moment ist, weil der Arme halt alleine spielt und rausgeflogen ist und so. Aber ich hätte noch alle Bären abgeschüttet. Ist dieser Handshake noch so eine gute Idee? Oder geben Sie sich wenigstens die Fault? Jetzt stellst du die wichtigen Fragen. Naja, bei einer Bahnsteig, die merkwürdig ... Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass du aufhören sollst. Du redest die ganze Zeit in mich rein. Nein, nein, nein. Ich wollte nur ... Nein, hey, ganz kurz, warte, warte, lass mich ganz kurz, lass mich ganz kurz sagen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass du auf dem richtigen Weg bist und weitermachen sollst. Du bist genau auf dem richtigen Weg. Ja, okay, aber du redest ja gerade. Du dachtest ja gerade, ich würde sagen, dass du es nicht machen sollst. Seit zwei Minuten sagst du mir, dass ich reden soll. Nein, red doch weiter. Naja, und dann verstehe ich halt nicht, warum die sich die Hand geben bei einem offensichtlich deswegen weird gewordenen Event. Ja, schwierig. Schwierig. Viele Skandale, viele, viele Skandale. Sachspieler geben dir teilweise nicht mehr die Hand. Oh ja. Und wie läuft das? Gibt es weniger Skala mehr Dolch? Bitte noch mal, habe ich nicht verstanden, den Catchphrase. Also, ich verstehe, dass du ihn richtig antagonistisch rüberbringen wolltest, aber dadurch habe ich ihn akustisch nicht verstanden. Dann lass mich anders formulieren. Das wäre mein größtes Akustik. Also als Bösewicht der Stadt, so Cowboy. Ich bin der größte Bösewicht und so. Und dann verspreche ich mich aber. Ja, das ist das Schlimmste. Weil, woher denn dieses Selbstbewusstsein und die ganze Zeit so arschlochmäßig unterwegs zu sein? Das verstehe ich halt nicht. Diese ganze Zeit so arschlochmäßig in dieser Stadt gibt es nur, in dieser Stadt kann es nur nur ich mach nochmal, in dieser Stadt möchte ich, weil du kannst ja, wenn du dich einmal versprichst ist ja alles vorbei, selbst wenn du es dann nailst, das ist einfach uncool ich möchte nicht, dass zwei Cowboys in dieser Stadt ist noch Platz für die Stadt für zwei ist zweitzeit also wenn man die Stadt aufteil ... Nee.
Ein kleiner Schritt für mich ... Nee, das war mein Punkt, ich will die Stadt nicht aufteilen.
Mein Punkt ist, die Stadt ist zu klein für zwei.
Ja, dann passt's doch.
Nein, noch mal, noch mal.
Hey, Joey, lass mich ausreden.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was das Problem ist.
Du musst mich ausreden lassen.
Diese Stadt ist nicht gross genug für zwei.
Ist nicht, nicht, ist nicht gross genug für zwei.
Ach so.
Zu klein für beide.
Okay, also du willst gehen.
Umbringen, ich möchte umbringen, die Luft ist mit Blei gewürzt.
Okay, jetzt, sorry, jetzt habe ich es, Entschuldigung.
Ja.
Sorry, jetzt habe ich es, jetzt habe ich es auch verstanden, Entschuldigung.
Ich weiß, ich muss es auf deutlich zu sagen.
Sorry, ich wollte dich jetzt nicht rausbringen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Du musst mich ausreden lassen. Ja, sorry, ich dachte dich jetzt nicht rausbringen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Stimmung ist irgendwie jetzt ... Ah, hey, mal, du hast die Stimmung verkackt. Bösewicht sein ist wie ... Man muss halt die richtige Stimmung. Es ist wie Sex. Ja, es stimmt schon. Man muss die richtige Stimmung haben. Ein falsches Wort kann alles ruinieren. Ein falsches Wort und die Stimmung ist ruiniert. Ein kleiner Aussprachefehler beim Dirty Talk kann schon alles kaputt machen. Kann aber auch, manche Fähigkeiten ist auch richtig sexy.
Sein ist so hart davor, richtig unangenehm Cringe zu sein. Wobei man natürlich sagen muss, für Cowboys im Speziellen übernehmen natürlich 80 Prozent der Coolness schon die Sporen. Also es ist schon schwer, uncool zu wirken, wenn du so kling, kling, kling, kling. Die Salontür.
Die Zwei-Stadt ist für einen Stadt, für eine Stadt.
Eine Stadt.
Komm noch mal rein. Diese Stadt hat für zwei für mich keinen Platz. Ähm, Derrick, richtig? Ja. Ist das hier Little Rock? Nee, ist Red Flag. Ach, fuck. Alter, das ist ja schon ... Das ist Red Flag.
Okay, ich wusste, dass hier irgendwas falsch ist. Ja, ne, also ...
Irgendwas, ich hatte es im Gefühl.
Okay, ich dachte schon.
Als draußen keine ...
Leute, die vorbeikommen, ne, es ist meistens was im Arzt.
Also, überdenk kurz deine Entscheidungen.
Ich hätte es aber merken können, dass man draußen sein Pferd nicht anbinden kann, war schon ein komisches Gefühl für mich. Ja. Das ist Red Flag. Ich bin ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, Sowjetunion ist für mich irgendwie eine Red Flag oder sowas. Wir hätten es wissen. Wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen. Viele Red Flags. Ja, ja jetzt raus mit Podcast-UFO. Okay, kommen wir wieder live getweetet. Aber jetzt gehen wir natürlich, das hat Spaß gemacht, das ist zu Ende. Weil jetzt gehen wir in den handwerklichen Teil über, wo Stefan Tietze Hammer und Meisel raushaut. Wir hätten es, schreibe ich auch, bei der Sowjetunion, too late, das Gegenteil von ist too soon, gell, bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen. Zu viele Red Flags. Doppelpunkt, zu viele Red Flags, oder zu viele Red Flags, nee, nee, viele Red Flags. Nee, zu viele Red Flags, oder? Aber das ist so weird, das würde das im Normalkontest nicht sagen. Wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen, so viele Red Flags, nee, nee, viele Red Flags. Nee, zu viele Red Flags, oder? Aber das ist so weird, das würde das im Normalcontest nicht sagen. Wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen, so viele Red Flags. So viele Red Flags. Ja, wir hätten es... Red Flags, wie schreibst du Red Flags? Klein und getrennt, ne? Nee, gross und getrennt. Gross und gross. Flags auch gross? Ja, wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen, so viele Red Flags. Okay. Kein Punkt, kein Komma. Am Ende des Tweets kein Punkt. Kommt auf den Tweet an, aber ja, ich würde das unterstreichen. Okay. Wir hätten's, würdest du beim Hattens so ein Paragraphen? Ja, würde ich schon machen. Ach Gott, okay. Wir hätten's bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen. So viele Red Flags. Doppelpunkt mag ich. Und danach Doppelpunkt schreibt man groß? Ja, gut. Einfach nochmal. Ich wollte nur nochmal nachfragen. Wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen. Aber Sowjet habe ich jetzt gar nicht darüber gesprochen. Nee, schreib so wie man Sowjetunion schreibt. Lösch den. Sowjet? Mit wie jetzt? Nein, einfach zusammen. Im Deutschen schreibt man Wörter zusammen.
Sowjetunion ist ein Wort.
Scheiße, aber schon viel gefällt mir Angaben.
Weg, löschen, löschen, löschen, löschen, löschen.
Nein, warte mal, kopieren.
Löschen, löschen, löschen.
Wer sofort liked, liked auch später noch.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich habe keinen Bock auf die Kommentare.
Gerade habe ich es noch anders geschrieben.
Sowjetunion zusammen.
Like ich gerne auch noch ein drittes Mal. Also, so, ne, so schreibe ich sowjetunion.
Äh, nee, ich glaube, das ist, nee, mit W, Sowjetunion schreibt man mit W. Aber jetzt, langsam finde ich es albern.
Das ist ein Handwerk auch, ne? Das ist nicht einfach nur hier Gags durch die Gegenschmeißen.
Aber Sowjet, also S-O-W-J, aber jetzt wird es ja-W-J. Ja, S-O-W-J. Sowjet. So wie man spricht eigentlich. Ja. Das klingt wie eine faule Sowjet. Wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen, so viele Red Flags. Es sieht viel unlustiger aus jetzt, aber mit dieser rechtlichen Schreibweise. Manchmal sind Facts auch einfach ein bisschen, naja, wir hätten es bei der Sowjetunion wissen müssen, so viel Refacts. Okay, gut. Gute alte... Sorry, wir mussten kurz mal unseren Nebenjob auch mal hier... Nee, aber das ist auch wichtig, dass wir mal wieder... weil früher war das das Podcast-Logvore. Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben einfach nur Tweets überlegt. Damals haben wir noch Hörer und Hörerinnen dazugewonnen, in dem Moment, wo wir das die ganze Zeit gemacht haben. Stimmt, heute verlieren wir. Heute verlieren wir. Nein, das auch nicht, aber es stagniert. Und das ist doch vielleicht wieder der Grund dafür, weiter uns zu hören und zu empfehlen. Man schreiben die einfachen Gag. Ja, genau. Also, wir bleiben dran. Ich versuche nochmal herauszufinden, wie es genau läuft mit der Losnummer. Aber wo dranbleiben, was mich natürlich interessieren würde, lass uns noch mal ganz kurz auf die Hausaufgabe eingehen, die du letzte Woche gestellt hast, weil die Leute wird es wahrscheinlich interessieren, wie es da weitergeht. Kannst du da einen Abwehr geben? Was? Baum, Gummibaum? Ja, der Gummibaum. Wie geht's ... Wie geht's dem Gummibaum? Ja, dieser Gummibaum. Wie geht's, wie geht's dem Gummibaum, ja dieser Gummibaum, dem geht's nicht gut. Ne, können wir das viel trauriger machen in diesem Song, weil dem geht's gar nicht gut. Also er fällt immer noch an Blättern, ich habe viele Nachrichten bekommen, die dementsprechend, wovor ich Angst hatte, grosse Angst, nämlich davor, dass sie mir sagt, dass die eine Hälfte sagt, du gießt zu viel, die andere Hälfte sagt, du gießt zu wenig und ich wieder an dem Punkt bin, wo ich vorher schon war. Jetzt habe ich viele Tipps bekommen, ich soll mir die Wurzeln angucken. Um es kurz einzuleiten, Stefan Titz hat Probleme mit seinem Gummibaum, er hat einen riesigen, extrem teuren Gummibaum, weil er ins Couch-Juck-Business einsteigen wollte. Leider geht das Ding langsam kaputt, wirft Blätter ab und dem geht es allgemein nicht gut, Mundwinkel noch unten. Und jetzt möchte Stefan dem wieder was Gutes tun, ein bisschen Bäuchlein reiben. Und jetzt ist er hilflos und hat nach Tipps gefragt. Und ich bin gespannt, was daraus wird. Erst mal hab ich ihn jetzt umgestellt an einen Ort, wo er gerade jetzt zu dieser Jahreszeit noch ein bisschen mehr Licht abbekommt, wo er auch gut war. Dem ging's ja auch jahrelang da, wo er stand. Jetzt ist er auf einem neuen Ort. Danach habe ich aber viele Nachrichten bekommen, dass selbst die kleinste Drehung den Gummibaum extrem irritieren kann. Also der ist wirklich ein bisschen so ein schwieriges Persönchen, kann man sagen. Ja, aber ist das nicht, also ich finde, ohnehin Pflanzenrotation ist mit so das Gemeinste, was man machen kann, weil die Pflanze wächst ja mit dem Wissen, wo die Sonne ist.
Aber du willst ja nicht...
Und die streckt sich ja auch dann in die Richtung. Und wenn du die jetzt umdrehst, dann ist es ja wie wenn die komplett ihr ganzes Leben falsch rumgewachsen ist. Aber die kann ja ganz, Pflanzenrotation ist ja wichtig, damit die gerade wächst.
Ist die Frage, also meine Wohnung sieht aus wie, ah, hier nimmt niemand sehr viel Rücksicht auf Pflanzen, weil ich mache das nämlich nie, und alle Pflanzen sind jetzt inzwischen auch schief. Alle Pflanzen wachsen Richtung Licht, und deswegen habe ich einen Haufen schiefer Pflanzen, und es sieht ein bisschen so aus, ob die aus meiner Wohnung fliehen wollen. Ja, aber wenn du die umdrehst, dann nimmst du denen ja das, was sie offensichtlich wollen. Das ist wie jemand nach irgendwas greift, also jemand sitzt auf einem Stuhl und greift nach irgendwas und du drehst den Stuhl dann so um, dass die Hand genau in die andere Richtung greift. Wie gemein ist das denn? Das ist super gemein, aber die können ja ganz einfach ihre Sachen drehen. Ihre Sachen? Da hast du jetzt aber, diese beiden Wörter übernehmen eine Menge Arbeit. Ja, die können ihre Blätter drehen oder nicht. Die können einfach ihre Blätter drehen in Richtung Sonne strecken. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht so schwierig für eine Pflanze, aber da seid ihr die Experten da draußen. Ich soll mir jetzt jedenfalls die Wurzeln angucken. Für mich klingt das alles ein bisschen wie eine Operation am offenen Herzen. Ich finde es traurig, dann gucke ich mir die Wurzeln an und dann soll ich was feststellen, weil natürlich sind mir gesunde Gummibaumwurzeln ein Begriff, also natürlich, weiß ich die kleinsten Unterschiede, merke ich. Ich glaube, je elastischer die sind, desto gesünder und wenn die so porös und hart werden, dann sind sie glaube ich nicht gut, das wäre jetzt meine Einschätzung. Wenn ich die auseinanderziehe und sie gehen von alleine wieder wutsam, bau bau bau bau. Ist es ein Dojojoing oder ist es nur ein Dojoing? Je mehr Ojojoings, desto gesünder ist der Baum.
Das ist der klassische Weg, um das rauszufinden. Ja, ich bin da dran, ich gucke mir die Wurzeln an, ich soll die Erde vielleicht austauschen und so. Und wahrscheinlich habe ich zu viel gegossen. Und das finde ich einen super tollen Satz. Ich habe zu viel gemacht. Stefan, schalt mal einen Gang runter. Ja, ja, du kümmerst dich zu sehr, du klammerst zu sehr. Unter uns. Ich hab nicht so aufgegossen. Ja, weil kann ich nicht, bin ich nicht der Typ für. Aber ich hab auch nicht zu wenig gegossen, weil ich glaub, der braucht sehr wenig Wasser. Und jetzt sagen mir Leute, ich hab zu viel gemacht. Es ist wie so ein Freifahrtschein. Jetzt mach mal weniger. Wenn man nicht zu viel gemacht hat und dann sagen einem Leute, jetzt überarbeite die. Ja, ja, genau. Ist toll. Nee, der Florentin hat ja schon so viel gemacht, dem können wir jetzt auch mal eine Pause gönnen und denkst du, ich habe überhaupt nichts gemacht. Aber man sagt dann trotzdem nicht. Ich sitze nur hier und drehe mich und mache gar nichts. Und drehe meine Pflanzen. Vielleicht solltest du einfach mal die Wohnung drehen, anstatt die Pflanzen. Das ist das gleiche Prinzip.
Einfach mal neue Einrichtungen.
Leider genauso. Ich habe jetzt alle Pflanzen, ich habe jetzt einmal rotiert. Ich habe jetzt quasi alle Pflanzen einmal an den Platz, an den Pflanzenplatz rechts neben den. Aber das heißt, für die ist es kein Unterschied. Doch, doch. Die Nachbarn ist immer noch Nachbarn, nur jetzt halt falsch rum. Ja, es ist jetzt alles ein bisschen an einem anderen Ort. Mal gucken, jetzt habe ich aber gehört, dass Platzwechselgummibäume extrem irritieren und sie oft alles abwerfen.
So aus einem Schock.
Hä? Wo bin ich?
Ja, chill.
Gummibäum chillert.
Was?
Hey, schau mal.
Hä, hä?
Schau mal.
Hä?
Chill.
Leute, fuck, fuck.
Du stehst zehn Zentimeter neben deinem alten Platz.
Ich seh's nicht. Ich seh's nicht, sieht alles anders aus.
Wenn du dich mal beruhigen würdest, würdest du es vielleicht sehen.
Es sieht nicht anders aus. Achte nur mal drauf.
Ich hab dich kurz ein bisschen nach rechts geschoben und leicht rotiert, so fünf Grad rotiert.
Wer ist das? Ich bin immer noch Stefan.
Wer bist du? Stefan, hey, hey, hey, bleib bei mir, bleib bei mir.
Du siehst so anders aus. Nein, ich seh nicht anders aus. Hä, wieso sehe ich anders aus? Ich sehe aus wie immer. Gut, ich hab meinen Bart ein bisschen länger jetzt. Wie riss ich das auch? Ich glaube, ich muss die einzige Reaktion, die ich hab, ziehen. Jungs, schmeiß die Blätter ab! Oh Gott. Schmeiß alle Blätter ab! Und dann... Weil die sind, wie gesagt, schwer und laut, diese Blätter, und die fallen, und immer noch reissen die mich nach so einem Schlaf.
Und jedes Blatt, der Herbst wäre eine ganz andere Jahreszeit, wenn die Blätter wirklich so, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, da, so runterfallen. Und immer, beim Einschlagen, dann wäre der Herbst einfach so eine unangenehme Jahreszeit. Ich finde Herbst auch nicht so angenehm, weil ich stelle mir immer, wenn ich einen Blatt fallen sehe, denke ich mir, bis gerade eben hing das so ganz knapp, nur noch mit den Fingerspitzen an der Klippe, ich schaffe es nicht mehr, ich kann nicht mehr und das ist der Moment des Scheiterns, den wir gerade verfolgen, wenn wir, oh toll, Herbst,, die gelben Blätter fein. Nee, es ist einfach nur die Kraftlosigkeit. Es ist der Ska-Moment. Genau, es ist der letzte Moment. Die Kraft hat sich das Blatt verlassen. Ja. Naja, ich schau mal, was ich da tun kann. Ich überlege ihn jetzt wieder zurückzustellen, aber dann krieg ich ihn auch nicht genau dahin, wo er vorher war. Es ist eine Shitshow. Der Gummi-Baum-Situation ist eskaliert, ich hab Barze voralltag habe den das Ganze vor anders hingestellt. Das ist alles ein Problem wahrscheinlich für den, ja. Und dann wurde mir auch gesagt, es ist okay, wenn er alle seine Blätter verliert. Der ist immer noch am Leben. Dann habe ich einfach einen riesengroßen toten Baum bei mir in der Wohnung stehen. Und dann sieht es auch langsam nicht mehr schön aus. Und jetzt soll man den ein bisschen zurückschneiden. Moment, Moment, Moment. Der lebt dann noch. Räume können auch ohne Blätter leben? Der kann auch ohne Blätter leben, ja. Also es ist nur Luxus, einfach ein zusätzliches passives Einkommen mit den Blättern oder was. Ja, es will sich einen schönen Pulli leisten. Braucht man nicht, hat man dann aber auch mal ganz gern. Pflanzen sind so ein Quatsch einfach, oder? Also sorry, ich will jetzt nicht alle Pflanzen mal irgendwie über einen Kamm scheren. Aber du machst es. Aber Pflanzen sind einfach Schwachsinn. Warum können die sich nicht bewegen?
Die bewegen sich ja langsam.
Nein, das ist ja nix.
Aber warum die immer so, komm, jetzt, voran.
Apropos nicht. Wenn die Sonne weg ist und der so.
Es gibt ja so diese Katzen, die sich dann immer so ein Stück weiterlegen, wenn die Sonne wandert.
Ja.
Und die Pflanze würde es ja auch gerne machen und die denken, ich komme aber nicht mehr.
Aber die ist halt noch viel langsamer.
Ich komme hier aber nicht raus.
Apropos viel, viel langsamer und apropos Halloween, egal wo du bist. Und in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem, in dem bin ich wieder zurück mit dem Fahrrad fahren zum Beispiel und es würde dann zu Fuß gehen. Das heißt, wenn man einigermaßen in Bewegung bleibt, ist dieses Wesen immer zu Fuß unterwegs. Das stimmt. Es ist ein toller Film, ich mag den sehr gerne, tolle
Stimmung, aber auch den Film, der
wahrscheinlich die dümmsten Fan-Theorien ever
hervorgebracht hat, weil ja Leute, ich
habe da Threads gesehen in diversen Foren
von wegen, ja, man muss alle paar
Monate, man holt sich zwei Wohnungen
auf zwei Seiten der Erde und man
fliegt immer hin und her und kann die Kreatur
auch schwimmen oder nicht hin und her und wie
halt einfach dieser stimmungsvolle Horrorfilm zu einfach so einer Matte, wenn es jetzt losläuft, wann ist es in Malibu und wann musst du den Flug zurück nach Deutschland nehmen, um dann wieder Zeit zu haben. Am besten wäre ein Zweitwohnsitz Neuseeland, Deutschland, wenn man in Deutschland wohnt und dann schafft man es ungefähr. Es wird so eine Reiselogistik mehr als zu einem Horrorfilm. Aber das ist ja die Prämisse und macht das ganz toll, finde ich. Es wird auch durch Sex übertragen, eine tolle Metapher. Ja, wofür eigentlich? Naja, schaut euch mal den Film It Follows an. Ich liebe deine Filmkritiken. Also, Filmanalysen sind immer so auf dem Punkt, so treffend. Nee, es wäre ein Herzog. Er hat gesagt, es ist eine tolle Metapher, ich weiß nur noch nicht wofür. Und finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Ja, so muss es sein, ja. Ich möchte auch noch empfehlen, natürlich, es sind keine Insider-Tipps, aber wenn die noch nicht genügt, Hereditary, ganz toller Film, Get Out, ganz toller Film, Der Exorzist, damals auch ganz toller Film gewesen. Ich mag die Insidious, den allerersten Insidious, den finde ich ganz super. Dann hat damals von unserer Serie der Maskenbildner gesagt, Wrong Turn sei ja sein absoluter Lieblingsfilm. Aus einer maskenbildnerischen Sicht. Okay, spannende Perspektive. Fand ich nämlich auch, und da habe ich mir nur noch angeschaut. Es ist halt super trashig, aber macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Eigentlich ein super lustiger Film. Klar, Cabin in the Woods gehört auch dazu, aber Wrong Turn möchte ich deswegen noch mal empfehlen. Ein bisschen ähnlich, abgelegene Hütte im Wald, mit Hilly Billys, die Leute entführen und essen, aber ganz toll, aus wohl maskenbildnerischer Sicht. Ich finde, man muss das immer dazu sagen, wenn jemand dir was empfiehlt, aus welcher Perspektive. Woher kommst du? Woher kommst du? Erzähl mal was über dich. Ich als, es gibt ja diese schreckliche Ich als. Das müsste man dann eigentlich dazusagen. Also ich empfehle dir jetzt hier diese Serie. Ich bin aber auch Beleuchter. Also die ist halt fantastisch beleuchtet. Die ist hell. Die ist unglaublich hell. Und das liebe ich ja als Beleuchter. Und ich liebe es, wenn das hell ist. Deswegen möchte ich den Film Sunshine empfehlen. Also wirklich, da siehst du fast nichts mehr. Es ist so hell. Blende Acht, Sonne lacht. Sie haben immer Bl Blende acht benutzt. Da gibt es übrigens auch sehr schöne Szenen in dem Monopoly-Doku, weil diese FBI-Agenten mussten dann halt diese ganzen Fernsehinterviews aufbauen, hatten aber keine Ahnung von der Technik. Und das heißt, du hattest an der Kamera einen FBI-Agenten, am Lichten einen FBI-Agenten, Tonmann war FBI-Agent, und die haben dann auch in den Talking-Heads gesagt, wir hatten keine Ahnung, was wir hier machen. Hier hat das Licht aber irgendwo aufgestellt und wir können froh sein, dass wir überhaupt was gesehen haben. Und dieses Material ist auch total trash. Warum müssen das denn alles FBI-Agenten sein? Weil du keine anderen Leute einweihen kannst in solche verdeckten Ermittlungen. Jeder muss sein FBI-Agent sein, auch der Assistent bringt Kaffee, ist dann auch FBI-Agent, es muss alles von denen sein. Und bringt dann sowas ganz anderes und Leute ...
Ja, das ist ja furchtbar.
... fliegen kurz, sind kurz davor aufzufliegen, weil er irgendwie was anderes bringt als Kaffee.
Weil er einfach keinen Kaffee machen kann.
Und offensichtlich auch das Tablett nicht halten kann.
Ja.
Interessant, das muss ich mal anschauen.
Also, ist das dein Serientipp für dich?
Ja, kein Horrorfilm, für alle, die keine Horrorfilme mögen, können sich Macmillions bei HBO anschauen.
Einfach mal reingucken.
Und ich bin in eine Scherbe getreten. Oh. Und tatsächlich, es war wirklich ein perfider Plan. Also es war, als hätte irgendeine übernatürliche Kraft versucht, mich zu erwischen und hätte wirklich alle Puzzleteile genauso hingelegt. Schritt eins, also Akt eins, die Glühbirne. In meiner Küche ist die Glühbirne durchgebrannt. Ich seheelle mir jetzt so einen Wes Anderson-artigen Film vor, wo dann so Kapitel eins, die Glühbirne. Akt eins, die Glühbirne brennt aus und ich habe eh schon zu wenig Glühbirne. Ich habe drei Lampen in meiner Wohnung und eine war eh schon aus und ich kaufe keine neuen und deswegen musste ich umorganisieren. Also ich kaufe dann keine neue Glühbirne, sondern ich... Du stellst die Lampen so hin, dass dann doch noch eine ganze Wohnung Geld ist. Genau. Ich schraube die bei einer anderen Lampe raus, also dieses klassische Fernbedienungsbatteriesystem. Du nimmst es von woanders und steckst es rein und musst dann taktisch überlegen. Ach, du nimmst, wenn du den Raum wechselst, die Glühbirne mit. So weit ist es noch nicht, obwohl ich gestern tatsächlich drüber nachgedacht habe, ob ich um den Hals so eine Glühbirne hängen soll, wenn ich einen Raumfalle, schraube ich die ab.
Aber jetzt habe ich gesagt, im Flur braucht man eigentlich kein Licht.
Nein.
Im Flur braucht man kein Licht, weil du hast ja...
Durchgangszimmer.
Genau, du hast Licht aus dem Wohnzimmer, du hast Licht aus der Küche, das trifft sich in der Mitte, gibt sich die Hand und du brauchst im Flur kein Licht.
Deswegen habe ich die Flurlampe dann in die Küche gehängt.
Jetzt ist die in der Küche aber auch ausgebrannt.
Und jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Probleme.
So, das war Akt eins.
Akt zwei, Husten. Ich habe wieder Husten bekommen und dachte, ich mache mir einen schönen Tee. Akt zwei, also ich gehe in die Küche, die ja jetzt aber dunkel war, versuche mir einen Tee zu machen. Der aber heiß sein soll. Während dieser ganzen Geschichte lasse ich die Teetasse fallen, sie zerschellt auf dem Küchenboden. Oh mein Gott. Akt drei, die Küche ist jetzt stockdunkel und es liegen Scherben auf dem Boden. Tritt in die Scherbe rein, als ich mir nachts noch ein paar Kirchen holen wollte. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt ein Problem, aber es geht. Hast du so ein Humpelnproblem? Nee, nee, nee, der Fuß hat ja diesen Bogen, ne? Ja, ist clever, der Bogen. Man tritt den Bogen, der Bogen. ja, weil der Fuß ist ja, hat ja diesen Bogen, ne? Ja, ist clever, ne, der Bogen. Man tritt nicht so doll rein. Das heißt, der Grössteil des Fußes ist gar kein Fuß eigentlich. Aber das ist gut, das ist gut, dass es bei dir so ist. Weil es so federt, ne, ein bisschen, glaube ich, das ist die Idee. Genau, also den Grossteil deines Fußes liegt ja gar nicht auf. Ja. Der menschliche Fußabdruck ist ja mehr so wie so ein Hund. Du hast so ein Ballen, dann hast du oben deine Pfötchen und dann hast du unten nochmal was, also du bist ja nicht komplett drauf. Flachfuss ist ja eigentlich schlecht. Plattfuss, genau. Je mehr Fuss du hast, desto weniger Fuss hast du eigentlich. Genau, Plattfuss ist schlecht, dann ist deine Körperhaltung ruiert und so und da liegt sehr viel vom Fuss auf. Deswegen ist das bei dir ganz gut. Aber heisst das nicht, dass es irgendwie hätte schlimmer enden können, natürlich hätte es schlimmer enden können, weil es ja auch auf dem da reintreten können, wo dein Fuss actually ... Genau, ich habe in diesem Bogen eine Verletzung, was aber nicht schlimm ist, aber zeigt, wie gross die Scherben waren, um das mal einzuordnen. Das ordnet es ein. Das heißt, ich kann es eigentlich relativ gut ... Es ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, dass der Grossteil des Fusses gar nicht gebraucht wird, du hast Fuss-Redundanz, und dann wirst du da getroffen und kein Problem. Von daher, ich bin jetzt aber kitzlig. Bist kitzlig? Ich bin vielleicht noch kitzligger, als ich davor schon war. Das darf nur niemand wissen. Mir geht es wieder ganz gut. Schulter-Schlüsselbein-OP, gut überstanden. Mir ist gar nicht aufgefallen, so lässig wie du hier gerade auf dem Tisch lehnst. Ich sitze lässig, übertreibe es ein bisschen. Wie gesagt, diese Gummibaum-Operation in meiner Wohnung war jetzt auch ein bisschen überdrieben. Und die Verhördokus haben natürlich ihr weiteres dazu gebracht, dass du versuchst, jetzt immer richtig zu sitzen. Ich rödel zu viel rum ein bisschen, dafür, dass ich noch, in meinem Entlastungsbrief steht noch Null Belastung bis Woche vier oder sowas. Da muss ich mal genau gucken, was ich da mache. Ich habe zum ersten Mal Krankengymnastik, auch in meinem Leben. Im Anschluss in dieser Aufnahme habe ich Krankengymnastik, muss ich mal gucken, wie das endet. I keep you posted.
Aber wie würdest du denn das Schlüsselbein belasten? Also kannst du einen Rucksack tragen?
Nee, da an der Seite noch gar nicht.
Rucksack ist, also das würde direkt in deinen Körper reinbrechen quasi.
Ich darf nicht belasten, meinen linken Arm nicht belasten, ich darf nichts hochnehmen.
Auch gucken, was ich mache.
Der nimmt ja den Liter schön rum mir.
Nicht schlecht.
Ja, das soll ich halt nicht machen.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt, die Versicherung, wenn ihr das hört, dann hast du ein Riesenproblem. Wie bist du eigentlich versichert? Gesetzlich, da kamen jetzt ganz viele, ich verstehe gar nicht, warum ich um dieses, auch dass du gerade meinst, der Gummibahn war so teuer, finde ich ja auch interessant, spannender Angle, dass du mich so darstellst, wo wir exakt den gleichen Job haben. Naja, und dann ja, aber kamen jetzt direkt Briefe zu mir, wo ich Auskunft erteilen musste, bei den lieben Herren und Damen bei der Versicherung, wie das denn passiert ist genau und wie gut das beleuchtet ist und so. Da habe ich jetzt ein bisschen Schiss, dass sie den Podcast gehört haben und die ganze Geschichte kennen. Aber es ist ein Comedy-Podcast, haha! Wir machen die Gags. Ja, genau. Satire, steht drauf. Steht drauf. Satire. Wir haben Satire drauf geschrieben. Das ist es auch nicht. Nee, ist es überhaupt nicht. Gut. Aber du kannst stattdessen auch einfach die Folge einschicken, oder? Statt so ein dummes Formular auszufüllen. Ja, genau. Hört euch einfach unsere Live-Show an. Ist, glaube ich, das Nervigste, was man kann. Genauso wie man fremden Leuten eine Sprachnachricht schickt, was das Nervigste ist, was man überhaupt machen kann.
So einfach alle Formularanfragen einfach füllt.
Ach, da habe ich mit meinem Podcast drüber geredet.
Hier bitte, Herr Lig.
Hier sind die drei Stunden.
Hier bei Minute 43.
Oder so, wenn du eine Autobiografie geschrieben hast
und die Leute fragen dich,
sag mal, wie war das eigentlich damals auf der Frank-Elster-Masterclass?
Du schreibst nur Seite 80 bis Seite 189.
Ja, Seite 88 FF. FffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffF-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F-F- Phasen von dir erlebt und ich glaube, du hast ein Leben, das kann man sehr gut in Kapitel packen, die verschiedenen Phasen, die verschiedenen Brüche, die verschiedenen Verletzungen. Und die furchtbare Tragödie am Ende, die vorprogrammiert ist. Das Brutsunglück. Soll ich jetzt schon mal anfangen zu schreiben? Ja, aber greif nicht vor. Nee, nee, ich spoiler nicht. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, du greifst vor und willst mich dann in so Ecken drängen, damit die Biografie spannender ist. D dramaturgisch wäre es jetzt richtig gut, nee, nee, nee, hör mir zu, dramaturgisch wäre es richtig gut, wenn du jetzt so wirklich in die USA gehst und so der aufstreibende Entertainer und nee, nee, und dann aber, nee, nee, pass auf, und dann aber scheiterst. Ja. Und dann so als der gebrochene Künstler zurückkehrst und dann Deutschland Dschungelkämpf. Ich kann auch nicht mit Ansage scheitern, ist doch bescheuert. Nee, nee, da sorge ich dafür, da mach dir mal keine Sorgen. Du gehst jetzt in die USA und du bist der große Reiter. Bist du der Grund, warum Kraren Schluss gemacht hat? Ah, ja genau, Kapitel neun. Florentin, bist du bescheuert? Na klar, die ganze Fremdgehsache, wie du es rausgefunden hast, das war doch super spannend. Es hat mich kaputt gemacht. Ich weiß, ich weiß, aber wie du dann wieder hochgekommen bist, das war doch toll. Das war nur Glück. Die Leute lieben das. Das hat sich verkauft wie Brot. Wie Brot. Alte Referenz. Naja, aber technisch gesehen verkauft sich Brot besser als geschnitten Brot. Weil geschnitten Brot ist eine Unterform von Brot. Es verkauft sich wie geschnitten Brot, sagt man, ne? Ja, aber Brot verkauft sich besser als geschnitten Brot. You skip the bread.
Ja, natürlich.
Also, Leute, das ist doch offensichtlich.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche, haut rein.
Und nächste Woche sind wir wieder mit dabei.
Leider nicht.
Ich möchte noch den Kino...
Aber nächste Woche läuft der Film nicht mehr, weil Deutschland dumm ist.
Schaut euch den Film Triangle of Sadness an.
Fantastischer Film, fantastischer Film.
Toll, toll, toll.
Gut, alles klar.
Dann wünschen wir euch noch eine schöne Woche
Haut rein, viel Spass mit dem
Gruselwochenende
Haut rein, macht's gut, tschüss, wir heben ab
Heben ab